hello everyone and welcome to pi data
global 2021 my name is camila and i'm
very happy to be here and be your host
for this session of lightning talks i
would like now then
to hand over to the first uh speaker
and it's going to be swear maria maya
and gus albulatova all right
hello everyone i'm sveyamari maya
and we're both developers at sktime
which is a unified and open source
toolbox for machine learning with time
series in python
and today we want to motivate why we
need sk time how you can use it and how
to get involved
time series are actually everywhere
whether you want to predict your cells
for the next season whether you want to
detect anomalies in your patient's heart
rate or whether you want to predict or
classify different brain states
so there are different machine learning
problems that correspond to these goals
to identify the type of signal that we
are observing we can solve a
classification problem so we train a
model on a set of labeled trained data
and then we use this to classify the
unlabeled data
to predict future sales revenue for
instance we'll solve a forecasting
problem we'll train a model on available
values and we will make the temporal
forward prediction on forecasting
horizon that we would like
to use in the future
there are also
a lot of other
machine learning problems that we can
solve with the time series data vector
forecasting annotation clustering and
many more
and for most of these types of learning
tasks there is already a great toolbox
out there in the python ecosystem
but this ecosystem for machine learning
with time series is quite fragmented and
these toolboxes are not necessarily
compatible with each other what do i
mean by that
imagine you want to make a forecast you
have a series and you want to predict
future values for this series
for this you could use the toolbox stats
models which provides many traditional
algorithms for forecasting
and the workflow looks like this so you
would first specify your model so in
this case that would be a zarymax model
and you would directly pass your data
that you might want to make predictions
for
then you would fit your model to your
data and thereby also pass additional
parameters that specify your model and
then you would call predict on this
fitted model with a start and an end
value
specifying from where you to where you
want to have your predictions
on the other hand you may want to use
profit so that's an algorithm developed
by facebook
and here you would specify your model
and directly pass the model parameters
you would then call fit and then fit
pass your actual data and then in
predict
uh pass a forecasting horizon which is
basically indices of where you want to
make your predictions
and so if you want to combine these two
algorithms in one application it
wouldn't be that straightforward and it
also wouldn't be that straightforward to
compare these two algorithms
and this is not only the case for these
two toolboxes but for many toolboxes
that are out there in this ecosystem of
machine learning for time series and if
you have these incompatibility
you
may still want to do tasks that you know
from sk learning so something like more
complex model building that includes
tuning your models or creating a
pipeline or ensembles
and this is quite hard if you have such
a fragmented system and this is where sk
time comes in our mission is to develop
a unified framework that covers multiple
time series machine learning problems
such as forecasting classification
clustering transformations and many
others and we do this by developing our
own algorithms and also interfacing
algorithms from the toolkits that you're
familiar with such as aforementioned
stats models profit and sk
learn
so our ultimate goal is to make
the ecosystem more interoperable and
usable as a whole and we do this by
providing consistent api
so this is what the example that we saw
earlier would look like in sk time
while these models are still interfaced
models from stats models and the profit
we are now having the unified framework
and it doesn't only make them
interoperable and
basically easier to use but also this
allows us building more complex
functionality like building for example
a forecasting pipeline so here you will
be able to plug and play different
forecasters in the same user friendly
api in a way that
you can do for instance in psychic learn
and so while we have already achieved a
lot so we have functionality for
classification for forecasting
for
um anomaly detection and you can build
an sk time
um pipelines and also ensembles there's
always something to do and we have a new
release every two months and currently
one of the goals or some of the goals
that we still want to achieve is panel
annotation functionality for change
point detection for segmentation or for
the classification of unequal length
data and that's what we need you for
sk time is not only a great toolbox we
are also a big community we are very
active and we are very happy to welcome
new contributors from different
backgrounds and on different experience
levels
for people new to open source
we provide our own mentorship programs
and also we are welcoming the interns
from external internship programs such
as google summer of code or outreachy
we are very happy to see you in our team
come and join us
thank you for your attention
thank you so much
i'm going to hand over now to our next
speaker
and it's going to be sarah schwehnger
hello
today i want to present you a python
package with which you can automatically
analyze the examined body parts in a ct
image
so in the last two years we have seen
that the analysis of medical images has
become more and more important moreover
the analysis of medical images leads to
lots of new opportunities so in this
short talk i want to go with you through
the pre-processing of a kubit-19 data
set
the notebook you can also find on github
at the python package page
or
in the description of the liking talk so
let's start
i downloaded the data from the cancer
imaging archive from the dataset
kuvit19ar i can totally recommend to you
the cancer imaging archive if you are
interested in analyzing medical images
because there you will find lots of free
and public data sets
so let's have a look into the data set
we have here a normal chastity scan but
we also have messy data in our data set
so here for example you find a corrupted
or invalid ct scan
here you find a ct scan where the lungs
were not fully examined
here you find a ct scan which is reverse
and here we have a ct scan
and where more than the lung region is
visible
so i have several problems with my data
set which i summarized here in the next
image and i define three pre-processing
steps to pre-process the data set so
first i want to remove all ct scans
which are corrupted or invalid
second i want to remove all ct scans
where the lungs are not fully present
and finally i want to normalize all ct
scans to the lung region if more body
areas are visible so my goal is to get
in the nct data set where all scans are
normalized to the lung region so that i
am able to further analyze scuba 19 in
the lungs
so during my master thesis at the german
cancer research center i developed a
body part regression model and i
deployed a python package to use it
so body part regression is
a my body part regression model takes a
ct slice as input
and predicts a single score and this
score is monotonously increasing with
patient height
and it tells us where we are in the
human body in an anatomical way
so for example for a three-dimensional
ct scan
every ct slice in the scan would be
mapped to a score
and we would gain in the end a slice
score curve for the whole ct scan and
with an additional reference table we
would be then
able to automatically know from which
area to which area our ct scan was
examined
so for example based on the reference
table we would know that the slice which
gets mapped to 0 corresponds to the
start of the pelvis region
so the body part regression model you
can also find on github
and you can easily install it through
pip install vpreq which stands for body
part regression
so to sum it up body part regression
takes a ct slices input and outputs a
single score
and this score is a kind of anatomical
height which tells us where we are in
the human body in an anatomical way
so
the main function of this package is a
function which creates for each ct scan
in a directory an additional metadata
file and statuses in a normal json
format and this metadata file includes
lots of body part related information
as for example the predicted slice force
the body part examined the validity of
the ct scans or the reference table
i already did that for the data set in
advance because it takes some minutes
but we can have now a look into the
metadata files and with the metadata
files i'm now able to execute all the
pre-processing steps
so here you find
the slice for curve and the predicted
body part examined from the metadata
file for the ct scan which you can find
below
and we see that the predicted body range
is chest abdomen pelvis and this also
fits well to the visible ct scan
in the next example the predicted body
range is chest and this also fits well
to the visible ct scan
here we have a very strange behavior of
the slicer curve it is not monotonously
increasing anymore and we have lots of
discontinuities moreover the predicted
body range is none
and that's because we have a corrupted
ct scan so with the help of the curse of
the slice book curve or with the
predicted body range we are also able to
detect corrupted ct scans
here in this chart you find the
distribution of the body ranges of the
examined body ranges in our data set and
we see that for most of the ct scans the
test was examined for some more than the
test was exam examined
some are corrupted or invalid and
sometimes the test was not fully fully
scanned as for example for the abdomen
abdomen pavers or pelvic ct scans
so now we can go through the
pre-processing steps first we wanted to
remove all invalid ct scan and that we
can easily do by just removing rct scans
where the predicted body range is none
this leads us to a new distribution
the next pre-processing step was to
remove all ct scans where the lungs are
not fully examined and this can be
easily done by removing rct scans where
the tag chest is not inside the
predicted body range so we just need to
remove the abdomen abdomen pelvis and
pelvis images
this leads us to
the new distribution of the data set and
now we have only images left when the
chest is imaged or more than the chest
regions image
and the final pre-processing step is to
normalize all ct scans to the lung
region this is a bit more complex but
not too complicated
so for that we need to have a look into
the reference table and there are lots
of different anatomical landmarks
defined as for example nearly all
vertebral of the spine
all landmarks like the lung start or the
long end and here in this table you find
an
example reference table from what one
meter data file and this basically tells
us which score corresponds to which
anatomical region
so for example what we see is that the
start of the pelvis corresponds to a
score of about zero
for the start of the lung we expect a
score of 44 and for the end of the lung
we expect a score of 75 and with these
two score boundaries of 44 and 75 i am
now able to crop the lung region out of
the ct scans
i also did that in advance because it
takes some minutes but we can have now a
look into the finally pre-processed data
set
so and what we can see here in the
images from the data set
is that we
created a data set where all ct scans
are valid and normalized to the lung
region and that we therefore are now
able to further analyze google 19 in
this data set and that we solved our
initial task
so thank you very much for your
attention you can find this notebook
also in the description of the lightning
talk or on the github page and please
feel free to reach out if you have any
questions
thank you so much for your presentation
sara i would like now to
hand over to faro
and he's going to talk about style
lightweight job orchestration for data
science workloads
thank you so much
my name is christian i'm a senior data
scientist at connected cars and today
i'm going to talk about how we solved
our data orchestration workflow in 10
minutes
so basically
[Music]
around a year ago we were where a lot of
teams probably are we were doing stuff
really simply for doing our data
pipelining essentially we could have
used cron but we ended up just having a
big while loop with all our jobs and
essentially it says if it's if it's
around midnight it's time to run to the
daily batch
do all jobs in sequence otherwise we're
just going to sleep
and that actually turned out to be
really good for us for a very long time
we actually really processed billions of
data points using this method and it
works out really well because it's
extremely simple and it's extremely
simple to fix
but there are also situations for
example with dependencies that are
really difficult to handle in such a
situation so we saw that we were getting
more data in and we needed to do
something differently
and we didn't we looked into all the
existing applications like airflow and
perfect and all those kind of things but
we wanted something that was really
close to vanilla python and we wanted
something that we were able to fix
ourselves so something really broke
and so we couldn't really find the
goldilocks product that we needed so we
ended up building it ourself
a side note on our photo structure we
have a very simple photo structure we
have a single source folder and then
there are all our scripts and every
script is
is located there so it's easy to find
talking about our dependencies we have a
bit of dependency spaghetti here on the
right so these are all our jobs and our
their dependencies so every box is
essentially a job that we need to do
uh
when everything on the left are jobs
that have no dependencies of their own
and everything on the right are jobs
that are not dependencies for any other
jobs so essentially you can see that in
the middle we have some jobs that really
depend on a lot um
and somehow we needed to handle that
dependency and we we really wanted some
solution that really would work in
in that setting
so essentially what we ended up with was
saying every file is a depe is a job in
its own right so every file in the
source folder is a job and then we added
in this metadata section at the
beginning called style config because
the product is called stout
and this mca it has a job type which
matches a file in the source folder it
has a chunk size that we use for doing a
task parallelization i'll come back to
that and then it has a dependencies
which is just a python list and each
element the list is a dependency so
another job in the source folder
that we can we can reference and then it
has a max lag which essentially says
that we need to run in this case we need
to run job b
if
it's more than 60 minutes since we last
ran that job
and then finally it has a main function
which essentially just says this is the
entry point for executing this job
so
very simple we have that in the
beginning of each file and that really
defines our structure so we don't have
any predefined pipelines we only have
the files and then they define the
pipeline so to say um so if you look
into what is actually the lifecycle of a
job
on the far left we have our periodic
scheduler which is built on top of ap
scheduler that is a python package
really nice python package essentially
just that does all the heavy lifting
with scheduling for us
it's when ap schedule says it's time to
do something submit a job then it's
going to add in a row in mysql
we have a single table in mysql that
handles everything so it drops in a row
and then we have something called the
master which is responsible for just
checking mysql saying
has there been any new work that we need
to resolve so in this case the master
sees that job a is in the queue it's
pending so what it does is that it goes
in and reads the job information from
mysql it imports the job using import
leap from the standard library in python
it reads in the style config section
looking at dependencies it finds it
loops over the list
reading in each individual element from
the list with import lib again and then
it does that recursively until it has
essentially built out the entire
pipeline
and after that it goes in and then it
pulls out the ids
that we want to work on and the ideas
are relevant because we need to know
what work do we actually need to do in
our case it's car ids but it could as
well be customer ids or
transaction ids or whatever it's some
kind of way that we need to map between
the job and the actual work
and that's what we do in in bullet 3.3
that's essentially we have the structure
that we want to execute a depends on b
depends on c and then we split that out
using these ids
to do task parallelization essentially
so when the master has done that we can
see here we have um
we have five or six we have six uh
pieces of work that we need to do
and the dependencies between them and
then we stuff that back into the same
table and then they are essentially
ready for the workers out here on the
far right and the workers are generic
they can do whatever job needs to get
done they just see the job name they
import the file using import leap and
then they execute the main function
so it's nice and simple in
in that way and when they're done they
just check back in
with the database and saying now i've
done this work
um
so so for us the last mile to production
used to be
quite hard
now it's more simple than that we simply
just develop and test locally because
everything is vanilla python you add in
the style config section so you define
the dependencies
you add the job to the scheduler if you
want and the scheduling file is just a
big dictionary with everything in it
and then finally you test and deploy and
again uh
works on my machine is of course
something that goes into this but um
essentially it's the vanilla python
executor in any sense so as long as your
con environment or whatever you use
match then normally it also works
against against production so this
really speeds up a lot of stuff for us
of course it doesn't really solve
everything
because we can have dependencies that
fails due to a wide variety of reasons
and this is really one of the things
that we're still working on in this in
this design um because in this case
b1 and then b1 job fails and then the a0
has to fail because it's dependent on b1
and if this happens due to for example
an i o problem with a database
connection or something like that we
could retry uh but if it fails due to a
syntax error for example because it hits
some kind of case that we normally don't
hit and then we can't really try and
and the problem we are facing here is
for example if something depends on a
let's see that job d depends on job a
then
job d is going to see that job a hasn't
executed so it's going to re-execute job
a job a is going to see that the b job
hasn't completed all its chunks so it's
going to resubmit the phase chunks in b
and then essentially that's going to
fail again if it was a syntax error for
example and then that's going to cascade
up and then if something also depends on
d you can see how this really quite
quickly can progress
um so we're still trying to recover how
do we do that when we don't have any
predefined pipelines but everything is
more dynamic so to say um
and uh the best options that we have so
far is either not to say we're not going
to run any anything that is has a
dependency that has failed but that's
going to stall some of our pipelines the
alternative is that we could go in and
say we return some kind of error code
specifying if it's a repeatable error or
non-repeatable error and then we could
we could retry in that sense and but but
doing this workflow where we actually
have um
where we actually don't predefine our
pipelines is something that we actually
found uh very useful in in our case
um
so is everything hungary and the traffic
is just flowing down the
highway is it we're in a much better
place now with stout but we are of
course not there yet and there's still a
lot of work that we we are working on we
still have things that breaks the great
thing about if things breaks now so for
example in this case if b1 breaks we can
go in
do a targeted fix
resubmit the code and then we since you
only need to rerun what was missing and
we know which was missing because we
have all the execution information for
the b and the a jobs so we're only
recomputing what needs to get recomputed
and that's a really nice place to be in
but we still have a lot of a long way to
go to actually also be mature there
um so if you have any questions i'm
available on slack for the remainder of
the conference you're also welcome to
connect with me and if you have any
questions we're hoping to open source
style at some point we haven't really
figured out how we're going to open
sources yet but i make sure to make some
noise on my github so if you want to
follow me on github and see the
internals of stout you're also very
welcome to to do that
thank you
thank you so much christian we have one
minute and 10 seconds left we have two
questions in the chat from bria question
uh for christian uh what lead you to
building your own system here versus
other options airflow ml flow etc
yeah exactly that's a great question so
we really felt that we we didn't want
anything like we didn't want anything
big we felt this is a simple problem and
we wanted a simple solution and doing a
big airflow setup or big perfect setup
with a separate server was really too
much for us so we decided trying to
build our own uh i would say it has been
an interesting experience and i would do
it again
but
but there are trade-offs and there is a
lot more that like there is a lot of
purification around using something like
airflow where you have a lot of other
setups but again it's a pretty simple
problem at least in our sense compared
to what else we do
thank you so much for answering that
question we have a question from roberto
in the chat but i don't think we can
make it in 10 seconds so i recommend
that you continue the conversation in
this like channel thank you so much for
being with us christian
thank you
i would like now to hand over to farooq
uh sheikh he's going to talk about
building a meta forecasting model with
prophet and lstn for time series
forecasting
hello everyone uh nice to see you all
so it's getting all too serious so let
me first crack a joke and then begin
with my conversation so where did all
the data scientists go
for camping on the weekends
i see no answer there so
they went through the random forest
yeah i'll share my screen and let's just
begin the presentation
okay so today we are going to talk about
how to build a meta forecasting model
with profit and lstm so uh the problem
of forecasting has been long existing
one and there have been multiple
approaches tried by various uh like the
organizations company to build a
forecasting model so what we have come
up with uh over here is a meta
forecasting model which essentially is a
combination of profit and lstm both of
them are open source libraries
and we are going to combine them in a
smart way and generate a forecast so
let's let's have a look at the challenge
that we have over here so we have we
were dealing with the data from mobile
telecommunication service providers
and their network actually gets
congested when there are a lot of num
they when there are a lot of users
trying to
get access to the internet at the same
time and that problem has only
exacerbated during the pandemic when
there are the demand has grown
exponentially and mobile operators had
to struggle with so all you need to know
over here is we are trying to forecast a
real-world data set and
the high value over here the high value
of the graph that we're going to show uh
are actually good for the network and
the lower values are the ones that are
critical and that is what leads to
congestion so let's take a look at the
workflow the data pre-processing in the
pipeline that we have built
so
the approach is quite simple we have the
raw time series available to us and the
first step that we do over here is fit
profit which has been developed by
facebook so we fit the profit model on
the raw time series that we have and
just get the output from it so step one
fitting the
fitting uh profit on the raw time series
in step two
we train the lstm which is the long
short term memory on the output of
profit
so whatever values profit has already
fit on the raw data set have been taken
and we have tried to fit lsa now the
reason we do this is because profit has
cleaned the data set it has removed all
the outliers and it has manipulated the
data while trying to fit
so it's an augmented data source that
we're trying to fit lstm on right now
in step three what we try to do is
we fit the same model that we trained in
step number two but this time around we
fit it on the raw time series just to
ensure that the model the lstm model
learns from two different variety of
data sources one from the values fitted
or fitted on the data set a raw dataset
and other on the values that have been
already uh the raw values so that both
can compensate and our model learns
something from two different but same
data source
and that gives us the final forecast so
uh let's see what how good or bad this
approach is as we go through so i'll
just go through the code very quickly uh
the entire repository has been uploaded
on the on the github i'll share the link
on slack as well as in the chat over
here and you can feel free to go through
it and let me know if you have any
questions or how can we or or i'll be
happy to hear your views as well so
let's begin with the code so here i'm
importing the uh all the libraries uh
i'm reading the data set i've created
the test train split over here uh 80 20
percent so 80 in the training 20 is the
training data set these are the lows
that i was talking about these are the
ones that are extremely critical for the
network uh service providers because
they lead to a lot of loss in revenue
and that is what we are trying to
predict so uh the accuracy of the model
should be very very high in trying to
predict the lower values
uh so here begins the step one we train
uh the profit on the raw time series
that we have over here so uh here is the
code for that
so one thing to note over here is we are
adding custom seasonalities because
based on my personal experience i feel
that uh the profit is not very good at
interpreting the uh the four-year
transform orders that that applies to
uh the training phase of the model so in
my opinion uh it would be better if you
add custom seasonalities and just set
everything before everything else
from the parameters to false
by that way you can get better forecast
so over here
i have trained the model initially you
can see uh that we have the output of
the profit model and you can see how
well the profit has actually captured
the trends and the seasonalities present
in data set these are the outliers or
the points that we are not interested in
the upper values so
the profit has very nicely neglected
them for us and it has cleaned the data
set that is what uh was like that is
what this step is intended for and it
has done just that so over here i've
just
broken down the learnings of the profit
into trends uh this monthly seasonality
daily seasonality and weekly seasonality
over here uh again we can see there are
all three seasonalities were present and
profit has done really well to capture
all of them
uh so next begins the pro process of
pre-processing the data for lstms so now
we are going to take the input from
profit and fit lstm on it so here are a
bunch of utility functions that just try
and address that uh but one thing that i
would like to draw your attention to is
the the function specified over here
which is which is uh the architecture of
our lstm model so one thing to note is
there's a problem of catastrophic
forgetting that we are trying to solve
in doing so uh
which is like the model tends to forget
when when we try to fit one model twice
i tend to forget what it had learned
previously so to avoid that we need to
keep the architecture of the network
very very shallow which it shouldn't be
very deep otherwise you'll suffer from
catastrophic forgetting so i've done
that and i've linked the description you
can read i've
linked the
this problem you can read more about it
the in the in the reference section
so here i've specified the hyper
parameters that i want to tune
uh here i'm generating the train test
and validation data splits
so here again i'm creating those data
splits and getting it getting the data
in the format for in which uh the lstms
would take it
so here begins the step two of the model
so in step two we are training lstm on
the data fitted by the profit so profit
uh is the the values that we obtained we
had saved them and we are training it on
them so over here we can see uh the
training has finished uh and
we get the
score of 0.25 at and the epoch number uh
after the 18 epochs
so we have obtained the
we have completed step two of the
training process now begins the step
three of the training process over here
we are going to retrain the same model
that we that was present over here uh
and we are just going to adjust the
hyper parameters this time around with
the raw data set so if you can see over
here the keras get such parameters i
have passed in uh the values that were
saved in the previous training phase so
kgs profit is what uh what we obtained
over here and have passed that as the
input for this step so it begins the
training again
uh reaches the conclusion like uh tries
to find out and everything is automated
using the keras hypertune library that
is available so i don't need to manually
manually tune the network it
automatically finds the best parameters
when it should stop the training process
because that is something which is
important and we should keep in mind uh
while while training this
this particular model
so over here the training has finished
and now we have we are just trying to
obtain uh the predictions from profit as
well as the predictions from the step 3
over here
now we need to have some sort of a
benchmark to compare the results to and
lstms have been gaining a lot of
popularity in decent times
because of their abilities to forecast
as well as their ability their their
other applications in natural language
processing so that is the model that we
are going to uh set as the benchmark so
i'm just setting the model just to
adjust the lstm model on the raw dataset
this is uh we're not training it twice
we're just training it once on the raw
data set which is usually the case which
is usually done by all the data
scientists so we do that over here
and we obtain the obtain the predictions
so
uh we now obtain we've completed the
training and we are obtaining the
predictions for the test set
and these are the values that we
obtained from the raw lstm the actual
values and the lstm profit metamodel
that we have built and here i have just
plotted uh how well the uh
the
two three two models that we have
performed with respect to the actual
values so we are forecasting 148 hours
into the future
so on the x axis you can see the number
of hours forecasted
so over here you can see that visually
it looks like lstm profit model has done
well but then again to get a better
understanding of how good this is with
respect to the
vanilla lstm model we are going to
compute the root mean square error on
both the both the methods and then
compare it so here here i've done just
that
here i've plotted the root mean square
error for uh profit lstm metro model as
well as the lstms and you can see that
for lstm it's 3.70 and for our meta
model is 3.2 which gives us around 13.36
percent improvement uh over uh
the vanilla lstns which is quite large
to be honest and i'm really excited that
this method has done really well uh
compared to the vanilla lstm uh that we
had
and like the entire process has been
automated so you can obtain fast quick
forecast and a reliable one just by
combining two or three different methods
that were available uh so the problem
that we had we addressed in this way in
this notebook i've linked it over here
the catastrophic forgetting you can
check it out and that code is available
on our github so i'll share the link and
very happy to take any other questions
you have or just uh like let me know
what you think about this particular
approach
yeah thank you so much
you see that was straight 10 minutes i
was already worried we were going to
have more than 10 minutes you made it
thank you so much i gave you two seconds
more because of the really nice joke in
the beginning thank you so much for your
presentation and for being with us uh
we have here some questions in the chat
unfortunately we don't have the time to
answer them i ask you to just continue
the conversation in this life channel we
have their talks just ask your questions
there just go together now do the
networking thing you know that would be
the place for it
yeah so i'll answer all the questions
from marcus as well as brian on the
channel that we have on slack so i'll
share the code as well as answer them
over there thank you so much
thank you so much for being with us
anyone you know yesterday i was holding
a session with the people from the
impact program and we had so many
amazing jokes you know like it was i
think the best data science jokes ever
but then i didn't save the chat and then
i like desperate now trying to find uh
jokes
this uh alexander here this one i heard
from vincent alvarez
yesterday credits to him
you know why tesla costs so much
they charge a lot
don't
thank you for that
i would like now to hand over to
abilash babu and he's going to talk
about using uh
scikit uh learn models in a cc plus plus
application
all right so the talk is about how to
use a
psychic model
to do influence in the cc plus plus
application so the outline of the talk
is that i'll go through some of the
available options
and mostly focus on only linux and uh
and if time permits show a little demo
of a toy application uh toy c plus which
application that uses a psychic model
inference
so
if you look at the
documentation for scikit learn
it
it gives you two different ways of model
persistence one is to save the model as
in the o index format and the other one
is to say within pml format
so if you are saving the model and or in
the next uh format then you could use
onex runtime for doing the inference and
that you could do it from a cc plus plus
application and which would be the focus
for this presentation
uh the other option is to use pmml
which is an xml based format and they
could use a cpm library for instance but
it's not very actively developed and
but
so i would not uh
prefer that probably oh nexus better
what are the other options uh you could
probably convert the model into a
library for example there's this library
called tree light
it converts a tree based model into a
shared library uh the downside is that
it works only with three base algorithms
like random forest or distant trees and
so on and
another option is hummingbird which is
another library from microsoft it also
does something similar it compiles
traditional machine learning models into
uh tensor computations and which then
you could use with the
traditional with the
any
deep learning mod frameworks like
tensorflow back and uh by tosh back and
or you know in nx
um the other option could be that you
use the same underlying library that
cyclic run uses for example lab linear
or liberty
but there's no direct mapping between
the way you train it on python and how
you use it with live linear on a c plus
will apply so
it might be possible to do it but it's
not it's not a straightaway option the
other thing that one could do is use the
python interpreter from c plus plus so
you could then wrap your python
application using pi bind or swig and
then
use it in this user application but the
downside is that there's probably loss
of performance because of the conversion
from data types in python and c plus
plus and vice versa
so yeah
so these are the different options that
are available
so we'll go on to the on the nx format
so it's the it stands for open neural
network exchange format so you could
save your model uh
in
in in this particular format which then
could be used by different frameworks
and
for inference so how does it look like
in a c plus plus application so here you
initialize the uh onex runtime and then
you create the session where you specify
the model and then you create the inputs
so you create the tensor populate the
inputs and do the inference and then get
the output so it's pretty
straightforward um now why or nx
because it's an open source format it's
been supported by like backed by all the
top companies working in this field it
works with all the different models
frameworks
and it also runs on different
a wide variety of targets
cpus gpus and fpgas with different
languages and the the other thing is
that say if you are working with a
traditional machine learning model and
you're not happy with it and if you want
to switch to a say a deep learning model
you could still use the onenext
framework because it works with the
other frameworks too so that it gives
you that leverage of trying out the
standard machine learning algorithms as
well as
deep learning models so the switch would
would be easier
uh the pmml model so it's a xml based
markup language so you can just like
odin x you can save the whole model the
parameters and everything in xml format
and then use uh
one of the libraries like cp mobile but
as i mentioned earlier it's not very
well supported so if you're into java
the libraries in java work very well
with pml format and if you're a desktop
application you say java based then this
could be a format that you could try
treelight as mentioned earlier so it not
only works with scikit-learn it also
works with xq boost like gbm so it
converts your tree light uh
sorry the machine learning model into a
shared library and then you can then
link it in your c plus plus application
so
the the conversion would look like this
so the the normal steps involved in
cyclic run you
you create the model
fit it and once you're trained you can
do call the export lib and
provide the tool chain
and then it converts it into say a
shared object if you're in another next
environment or a dll if you're in a
windows environment
uh the same is the case with hummingbird
so you
convert the whole thing into
different pack-ins so you can convert
your
mo clear tree based model into a pie
torch model or an oven and x or a batch
a tvm and then you could use their back
and like the tripod back end or oven nx
run time to do the inference
so here's the uh screenshot of how you
could do that so
again the same steps uh create the model
do the uh
fix the model and then you can convert
it into
whatever back-end you want to prepare it
for
so uh
the links to all the different libraries
that i've mentioned earlier
it's here and now time for a small demo
so
this you could could you see the
uh
application
yeah okay so this is a uh simple sports
application where
you can just toss digits and do the
prediction for example you can say
draw two and i hope it works yeah so uh
okay so this so this is a c plus plus
application uh and it it does inference
on a support water machine model a
logistic regulation and a random forest
so you could say
draw something and
predict and it'll show what it predicts
for different models so
yeah
not very user friendly but
so
uh
so it uses all these different models
and uh it uses the o in the next runtime
that i mentioned earlier in the
presentation
so yeah that brings to the uh
brings my presentation to
thank you so much for being with us a
blush
thank you
i would like now to hand over to brian
said my neck
and it's going to talk about pointer
generator summarization and
explainability for legal documents
cool thanks um and yeah so happy to be
here um and i guess i'll start i'm brian
chipmatic i'm a data scientist at
thomson reuters labs in in london uk
and this is my first talk so if it's
terrible please be nice but also feel
free to um you know send me an angrily
worded email or slack message later
telling me what to do you know what i
did wrong it's always good to learn so
um also this talk is um also largely
kind of like an industry talk around the
human aspect of translating models to a
human driven task so i'm a little bit
light on the technical technical details
of the models but please feel free to
ask
i also have way too many slides and i'll
click through them really quickly but
hopefully that will help gloss over the
fact that i don't really know what i'm
talking about so
yeah we'll go from there
okay oh and yeah sorry i'm talking about
pointer generator summarization and
explainability
corporate stuff out of the way thompson
writers labs is the you know little
startup inside of the the big
corporation like every company claims to
have uh we are hiring and it's not a bad
place to work i will be posting in the
jobs slack channel um as well feel free
to like message me on linkedin or here
something like that um yeah so cool
awesome so i'll spend about five minutes
on text summarization and then about
five minutes on explainability um i'm
usually pretty cool to take questions
during a talk but i can't quite happen
to see them at the moment so maybe i
don't know raise a hand or shout out but
otherwise we can take them at the end
okay so i'll talk about the use case so
most people probably know thomson
reuters for reuters news
but that's actually just like the
tiniest part of the part of the business
the the largest part of it is actually
products for tax and legal professionals
and one of those is called courtwire
and corewire is a product for legal
professionals to monitor new legal cases
as they arise specifically across the
u.s
and the idea is that we have to get them
to publication as quickly as possible
for for people to firms to read them and
kind of choose if they're going to
represent cases
and usually courtwire gets stuff out
kind of like two weeks before um
the court docket which is a big rush
right for for firms
so um the kind of workflow is that a
court case is filed to the court some 10
or long you know 100 page document is
published um we send it off to legal
professionals expert editors they write
some kind of summary about it which is
what i'm talking about but they also
extract a whole lot of metadata and then
they publish this out to our clients for
them to read and they kind of choose who
they want to represent for certain cases
okay
what this looks like under the hood for
our internal editors is they get a pdf
document
and they have to go through this manual
task of reading the whole document
and writing up some you know very
exacting summary as well as that
metadata that i mentioned and just you
know to be really clear in the legal
field um the quality of these summaries
is of utmost importance which you can
you know imagine why because legal
proceedings are usually a very language
specific and very
um you know situation specific so you
have to be quite exact on them
um and so this is the this is the kind
of case that we wanted to replace where
we have this summary task which is time
consuming and we were hoping that we
could just completely automate it away
which as we know in machine learning is
usually a pipe stream to fully replace
people
okay um so our task is pretty clear um
from the the source data we had we get
pdfs that are ocr'd we have about a
million historical cases as our training
data sets um the first model was trained
until about 2018 and now we're kind of
updating it so it's a bit more than that
and then editors say that usually in the
first 10 to 15 pages of the document
they can write a good summary so while
this is technically a long document
problem it's not a like massively long
document problem
and then our target is a summary is
going to be kind of one to two maybe
three sentences long
the the human cost of it is about six
minutes per editor summary so anything
we can get below that is good
and as i mentioned the quality of the
the summarization is extremely important
so you know any model we produce has to
be very good for that
okay um just a really quick introduction
to summarization most people probably
get the idea of text summarization but
it does break down into two large
areas the first being um extractive so
that's just you chip and
sorry you you strip out sentences or
parts of sentences and you kind of mash
them together into hopefully a condensed
summarization
or you have abstractive summarization
which is more kind of your like middle
school
book summary thing right like take this
long thing generalize it into your own
words and hopefully you have just a
shorter condensation of it okay so those
are the two things um and i just i have
my own kind of informal rules around
what a good summarization should be
um these are not like formalized
anywhere it's just i think they're um
good that the summary should be shorter
than the input text it should capture
the salient information it should
faithfully represent the document right
like you can't have non-factual
information provided
if something says the revenue value is
10 million you can't say 15 million
and also it has to have some kind of
grammatical and syntactical
properties to it that we you know would
like to read as people
okay
cool so to do this um there are a lot of
summarization models of kind of varying
levels of state-of-the-artness
we went with a pointer generator network
which
kind of 2018-ish was a bit more
state-of-the-art
it is a sequence to sequence type model
which has a pointer which improves the
accuracy of the model by handling
um out of vocabulary words so this is
our extractive portion of the network
um and this is what gives us the factual
stuff right like pulling out that
revenue value of 10 million um exactly
as opposed to trying to reword it as
some approximation of it right
um
and then there's the generator network
which again is kind of your your
summarization and this is what gives you
that idea of um
of of incorporating uh paraphrasing and
generalization to it
and you kind of shove these together and
get an extractive plus abstractive model
which is pretty neat
the the kind of technical details that
i'll gloss over but i really want to
point out is the interesting part is at
each stage in the
um network decoding time step you had
you get um within the pointer net as
well as a baseline some probability for
generation to occur and that's what this
p-gen is
um and you sum those up at the end and
that's how you balance the extractive
versus abstractive nature of the network
um there's a there's kind of like a
default value you can totally fiddle
with it if you want
um but at the end of day we found that
when we trained it on these kind of
million or so documents we actually got
pretty good machine generation it was
around 70
um
and then we started displaying this back
to our editors and now you know we
thought we did a great job and here's
your summary and it can speed up your
time and then all the editors came back
to us saying no no no um you have this
summary but how did you get there like i
can't trust this i still have to read
the entire document at which stage i
might as well just write the whole
summary myself all over again right so
we found that we really didn't solve any
of our our use case problem to write
these summaries
so that gets us to explainability that
we know we had this model that was
presumably outputting something useful
um but the the editors who are not
machine learning experts didn't know
what was going on um so now we're left
with explaining this
so um and here's kind of the crux is i
have a chip on my shoulder about
explainability and ai whenever somebody
says that
ai models are black boxes that's not
true we just have to you know tease out
the nuance and think about who we're
explaining stuff to right as an ml
person you might want to care about like
does it work as expected what are the
data biases
if you're a regulatory body you might
you know especially with gdpr you might
care about are these things um biased do
they comply with regulations
or in our use case we have an end user
who wants to say can i trust the model
is it outputting the the salient
information where did you get this
information from
so we said okay well how can we point
out to the user what is the model
actually paying attention to
within the
pointer generator framework there is
this attention distribution layer
that you can pull out and with a little
bit of normalization you can pull
together this really nice
word highlighting matrix and from that
all we did was just overlay into the
summaries where the network was actually
pulling and generating these summaries
from so that an editor could go in and
say oh it's at least bringing me to the
place that um these things came from
okay
and so at the end of the day um there's
some text but the point is we saved
overall about 37 percent of of editor
time in the summaries which was
definitely like you know um a great a
great time savings for us and yeah so
that was that project now i feel kind of
bad because i did talk about like an
internal thomson reuters tool but
there's a fantastic open source repo
called echo
that does
much more than what we did as well
where it actually gives these kind of
highlights i am running out of time i
think i have five seconds and um please
go check it out it's fantastic and yeah
thanks everyone for listening and maybe
q a at the end
30 seconds 29 if you want to say
anything else
oh just my my takeaway is that um the
obvious solution
that full automation was like not gonna
happen um but it just
it's a shift of task to what the editor
actually wanted to see which is where is
the summary coming from and i think yeah
ai is explainable just you have to put
some effort in
thanks everybody
thank you so much brian for being with
us we have some questions here in the
chat we don't have the time we don't
have the time to answer to them uh but
if you want please do come continue the
conversation on this lecture and you'll
go there to talks and uh please just
continue there in the other town thank
you so much brian for being with us i
would like to hand over now to diego
arenas and he's going to talk about
automating the exploration of databases
for data science with aeda
aida
thank you camila um can you see my
screen
yes we can
great
my name is diego arenas i'm a computer
scientist i'm finishing my doctorate in
computer science at san andreas
university and i work in data science
and data engineering projects and before
that i did a master's in data science
and before that i was a consultant in
data analytics
and i had in
during all these kind of experiences i
had a recurrent problem all the time
when i started a new data science or
data engineering project
which was
um the customer or my new project handed
me kind of a big data set or a new
database that
in order to create a machine learning
model or
to design a new data data model so
i
found myself all the time doing the same
tasks over and over again like
how many tables how many columns um
doing a lot of data expiration so
because of that
of that problem recurring problem
i tried to reduce the time that i would
spend querying the data and more time
analyzing it so i created this um custom
package um called aida ida
you can i added the
you can find the slides
in this webpage
basically
the aida ida library stands for
automated exploratory data analysis
[Music]
it works with
two databases so you will have a new
database that you want to kind of
explore and understand its content and
your the package requires a second
library a second database where you will
store all the metadata from the original
database so you could have a
multi-gigabytes or terabyte database as
a source but when we extract the
metadata we turn that into megabytes so
it's easily explore
afterwards when you kind of profile the
database
it works extracting the metadata
and it automatically creates a data
catalog
for you
the way it works basically it generates
sql code and it's executed on the host
on the database
host server so
if it's big enough to hold the database
to help it to have the database it can
support the queries for for exploration
at the moment um
it um it supports
these databases but it's easily
extendable so
another thing that i wanted to do is was
to make it as simple as possible um
so
the user
shouldn't have to configure too much
things
[Music]
so
um
it works for mysql postgres sql server
oracle as well snowflake and
if you have a different database engine
it could be easily extendable for for
that um
so what do you do when you
start exploring a new database and some
ideas are
to know how many tables what are the
names how many columns what are the
names how many rows
are in the in each
table how many unique values you have
how many know values you have an
assessment of the data quality of the
database the source database
for categorical
variables or columns you would like
probably the distribution what are the
most frequent values what are the less
frequent values
for numerical
columns use like the average standard
deviation maximum minimum different
percentiles like medium
5.5
and so on some different
statistic moments of the variables
and for daytime columns it would be nice
to have
a summarization so if you
have a timestamp somewhere you could
aggregate that
by month and see trends if the data
grows or decreases what are the limits
the ranges of the data and so on so all
these things um
the ida library does it for you in in
but
with a single command and it generates
all this information and made it make it
make it available for you in a metadata
database that you can query or
connect to your to your kind of
preferred
data visualization tool
how can you use ida and please do
let me know how it goes and if you want
some help reach out
i'm happy to
[Music]
explain but basically there is a file a
database.ini file where you define this
connection
you will have you will need a
source database that you need a reading
access
and you define the standard the name of
the database the server the
ip in the host
a user a password and you define a
second database for your metadata could
be local
if you don't have a database it will
create a sqlite local file in your
in the repository that you found
that will store the metadata there
you will need
those names you
name the your connections basically
these are your connections then from the
terminal you just need to run python the
ida this is the main file
explorer this is the command and you
pass
your source database and your metadata
um database
and this will generate i will start
querying the
source database and generates i've
explored or
profiled hundreds of tables like um
databases with hundreds and something
with thousands tables and doing that
manually would be
feasible but would take a long time so
this is kind of a time saver
basically
and
there is embedded in the or incorporated
in the
library there is a
very lightweight data visualization that
you could explore the data with
streamlits and basically list the tables
and give you some
summarization of the information that
you have and it does that
based on this parameter metadata
database yes basically it will kind of
connect there and create the
visualization the good thing is you can
query or to profile different database
engines and store them
all together in your
metadata database and explore all them
together at once
while using ida is a centralized
metadata repository
it's
there's a lot of features to add but
you could easily start exporting
databases with this and then you could
probably move to a more
uh
developed solution but this is a kind of
really straightforward start
um
it reduces the data collection time and
you have more time for analysis
um
you can query your different
database engines without need to don't
need to change you kind of query the
data and data values from from
your metadata database
it finds relationship between tables
as well because we will have the domain
data so you could search the domain
values for one column on the domain
values of all the other columns of the
other
databases or database engines you can
have a high quality assessment for free
and
yeah these are one nice feature that it
finds candidate primary keys from
database models sometimes you need to
find the primary keys but you don't have
indexes or anything
and this
script will do that for you basically
will tell you
which
columns are
looking more promising as candidate
primary keys on the table and that's
very helpful for bid engineering
problems for cbc and
other
type of
problems maintainability
and
here i'm just showing a
bit of visualization that i queried 800
tables and with five million pros um
and
it depends on how much time it takes for
the server to to finish but all the
queries are sorted by row number so it
will
finish the
small tables first and then we'll take a
bit longer for the bigger tables but
eventually it finishes and you can have
something like this this you can build
your own data visualization and for
example for time stamp values you could
select any time some value and see the
trends
and group by month for example for each
or any table
thank you very much if you want to
get in touch or try out
at least
create an issue on the repository and or
ask any question and i'm happy to kind
of get in touch and
try to tell you more about either how to
use it thank you
thank you so much diego we have a
question in the chat from uh rebecc does
it support azure active directory with
mfa authentication
so the answer is planning to accessing
connections with connection um
to a key value in azure and
have that
kind of level of security but at the
moment
okay thank you so much diego for being
with us here at pi data global
i would like now to hand over to makeup
fluge achilles uh kotsu and mikhail
zontag
and they're going to talk about gene at
home run your own research data
management platform
and alexander told me before he had a
joke but i'm not sure if you want to
share about it about a favorite python
library so i don't know if you want to
do it now or later
[Music]
maybe we go first with the presentation
and then we have the python joke please
[Music]
yeah thank you camila
and yeah i will
talk about so i'm mikka pfluger
and i'm we'll talk about jin at home so
run your own research data management
platform
and
so first i will tell you about the
problem that this solves and
what the solution is
that
i will talk about so the problem is
and you probably all know that version
control is great and then the idea that
you directly have is let's also put all
our data in probably git because you're
doing the version control of your
code
in git
and that's actually something which
works at first
but then you quickly notice that
github where you probably have your code
blocks pushes that exceed 100 megabytes
and it's rather quick to have a data
file which is larger than 100 megabytes
and even if you look around for other
git hosting options
um
gitlab.com for example has a total
repository repository size limit so that
is also not very
not probably not enough if you have a
bit larger data
sizes
and then
even if you say okay we will be hosting
our own gitlab um
the problem is you don't want to version
control one version of your data the
whole idea about version controlling
this is that you have different versions
of your data set you iterate rapidly
like maybe multiple times a day you
change something there and then your
data set and your git repository grows
and cloning your git report repository
will take forever and also all
operations will take forever it's not
actually built for this
um
so let's see what the idea for the
solution is
and that is jim jim is the software
and what does it do
think
like github or gitlab it's git hosting
but it also handles large data
and it does this by putting the metadata
so the file size and the hash of the
file
and the file name into git
and the data in git alex which is
another program
that exists that is older
that puts the data close to git but not
in git
and one of the big
advantages there is that the data is
only fetched on demand so if you
clone your data set at first you only
get all the metadata and then you can
for example say
get me the most recent data and you
don't have to have all of the versions
of the data set on your laptop
and the clients that you would then use
because i mean you can use git
and get annexed directly that is
possible with gin also but it's
a bit raw
to do that and there are more polished
clients that are the gym command line
interface
cli and data led which is
geared more towards scientific
publishing
so that sounds good to you i guess
so when you sign up and that depends
if you do neuroscience research data
then you actually just sign up at
gym.gmo.org
and
i mean i can show it quickly to you this
is a
web page
you can register there register there
they do lots of nice things for example
also you can get a
doi for your data if you want to
and um
it's recommended
also by the big publishers there
and just one fine print
do con
contact the people there at g-note
before uploading more than one terabyte
of data so i mean it's not a hard limit
but talk to them before you do that
unfortunately
you might not be doing neuroscience
research i am not doing neuroscience
research so what do we do
well
that's the real topic here it's that you
just set your own up your own
gym so you can set up your own gin
because it's a free software
and
it's not actually that hard i mean of
course you need a server and the server
needs to have a lot of storage as much
as much as you want to store their
different versions
and technically this is packaged in
docker containers by the jin people
and it can be installed
all the docker containers that are
necessary and all the configuration and
so on using ansible which is a
configuration management system
and that's the part that i developed
and when i talk to you about minimal
config i will just show a fairly minimal
minimal config that you have to write to
deploy your own
gen
and there you can see you just write uh
on which host you want to install it
um
you tell the name
uh of course you need a domain
uh you have to give some
admin username so the first user that
will be configured and then later you
can say
if people can sign up or if you
have to make new accounts manually for
example for an internal installation
and if you want to send mails stuff like
that there's a lot of more configuration
examples to uh configuration variables
to configure your own gin
um
but i will not show all of them here now
and this is really enough to get get you
up and running and the nice thing with
ansible is also if you want to change
something here you just change it and
rerun it
and it will change the configuration of
your instance
so that's it
um
i want to say thanks to the gen and data
lab developers i mean
i didn't develop
this stuff only the installation routine
and um
you can find the ansible role and also
the documentation here at also at github
or at the ansible galaxy you can find
this slide
at my personal
page and thank you for listening
thank you so much for your talk nico we
have some questions in the chat
uh from abilash in huawei is different
from git lfs
yeah
it is
slightly different from git lfs
mostly in that you can use
with um the clients for example like
datalit you don't have to use gin
um
you can also use
other um
back ends so for example just an ssh
back-end or you can put your data into
large
cloud storage providers
and
then what the other question was in what
way it is different from dvc
there
it is
more going into the um details to see
where it is really geared towards dvc
when i looked into it a year ago
was really
had special features for this
um
[Music]
for the integration
of machine learning stuff whereas
jin came more from the
data science side i would say
and
[Music]
especially data led there has
reproducibility features that work
differently from dvc
and is it usable for data sets on the
order of one petabyte the data that
definitely is so the neuroscience
research
that people are doing there is done on
this
order of one petabyte or more
but
i
haven't myself tried if the gin web
interface then also works nicely so that
is
of course something that also depends on
your server you need a server where you
can store one petabyte and it needs to
be a web server so that might not be
straightforward so you might want to use
other backends there maybe that's also
not so critical that people could
download one petabyte
in their browser
thank you
i would like now to hand over to uh
sebastian
ends and he's going to talk about
amazing things your unix operating
system can do for you ozek's shared
memory
uh thank you
uh good afternoon everybody my name is
um i'm basically a self-employed slash
freelance consultant you could say
mainly working in high performance
computing stuff i do a lot of
geoscientific work but also aerospace
engineering work and whatever is related
to that
and this talk kind of came out as a
just a site result or kind of a little
thing on the side basically from a
conversation i had with a couple of
people and was kind of interesting to
see
so every now and then i have to dig into
infrastructure when i do parallel
computing and i have to solve stuff and
make stuff faster as you want maybe have
to so in parallel computing you usually
have to deal with the issue of
efficiency sharing data across
parallel portions of a computation and
when you write the code like one portion
is computing one but then the other
portions could be the other bit and you
have to maybe exchange intermediate
results and there are different
strategies for that as you may know
so when we are working with python
basically we are confronted with the
typical problem of the global
interpreter log so basically
uh you cannot really do threat based
parallels the main python you can do it
in c and fortran c plus plus but you
basically cannot do it in python
my apologies to interrupt you uh we have
a request on the chat if you can speak a
little bit louder and slower yeah it's
hard to hear you
okay so in python you cannot really go
uh with a motive multi-threaded parallel
computing task for most intents and
purposes which is essentially why you
want to
use multiprocessing essentially
going one step further uh well if we are
going for multiprocessors
we are dealing with memory protection on
modern modern operating system meaning
that one process cannot easily share
memory with another process because of
the memory protection
remember the days of windows 95 when
everything was crashing all over day of
the day after day this was an operating
system that did not have memory
protection hence that's an issue we
typically address this within a process
communication
now what is it one of the typical
solutions in python is something like
number for instance if we jit compile
stuff with number
we actually now have a binary code
essentially which can again use threads
number does not care about the global
interpreter lock and
if you're using it in no python mode so
this is one solution there is the p
range function essentially which is
something that you can use
i'm calling it cracking walnuts with a
sledgehammer it's kind of a hard thing
to do on some pure python code but
it usually works
if you're interested in going faster you
can kind of go for the nuclear option uh
siphon you basically take python chord
uh converted to c and then you compile
it again there's something called a p
range in here which is kind of still
python-like syntax but you kind of get
something parallel working again threat
based
but what about pure python like how can
we actually do something in pure python
have full parallelism and still have
shared memory like as if we were in
threats so this is kind of the idea here
and this is where posix shared memory
becomes a really interesting tool to
play with
and this is something that i have been
exploring uh quite a bit
so this little snippet here don't read
it in detail just skim over it uh
something i came across a while ago
it's basically
four functions from lip c something that
you would typically find on the unix
operating systems system uh shm get
dt and ctl and you can kind of
understand them as a kind of version of
malloc and free
shmgat and shm control and in the middle
you have the attach and detach methods
and what those are is essentially
functions to tell your operating system
that you want to have a special chunk of
memory which can basically be shared
among processors
so there are some limitations to that
usually it depends on the configuration
of your operating system you can share
an average usually a few gigabytes but
you can up the number you can
reconfigure your os to handle more like
that so this kind of gives you actually
a proper method to kind of allocate
memory and then you simply tell the
other process hey here's the memory we
want to share and suddenly you have
shared memory across processes
so this is kind of an amazing tool but
you still have to kind of put this
into something you have to wrap this to
make some proper use in python so i did
a little proof of concept
and uh i will show you the code later
but bottom line is i wanted to have
something like the p range from number
or from siphon but i wanted to have this
in pure python and i wanted to be able
to share something like numpy arrays or
similar data structures so i could have
my parallel computations
so i thought hey i need something simple
like a decorator you are familiar with
that i guess and like an openmp maybe i
want to highlight what is a thread local
variable and what is a shared variable
like in this case in line five you can
see i want to share the parameter
parameter a that goes into the p range
function and then inside the function i
have a p range that actually splits
the python interpreter into processes
and then allows to do parallel
computations this is actually feasible
in python and i thought wow this is
amazing
now why aren't people using doing that
and as it turns out there are proper
implementations for that and this is
kind of what i want to highlight here
because
from my perspective this is kind of a
forgotten niche in the ecosystem
so first of all uh the multi-processing
uh kind of uh library that is part of
the pure python vanilla standard library
has a new edition the shared memory
module which was added in python 3.8 so
this essentially allows you to have
something like normal python lists
actually which are distributed across
multiple pipe interpreter sessions on
processes this is kind of amazing for
normal python and if you are needing if
you're looking for arrays that are
shared there's actually also another
package which does exactly that it does
kind of numpy arrays with all the kind
of features that you are expecting you
can run your ufo funks against them and
do your stuff and shared arrays is
exactly this python package which is
doing this kind of thing
so now you can use multiprocessing spin
up multiple processes on one machine
allocate the numpy array through shared
array and just spread it and you
suddenly are in a world of normal shared
memory as if you were doing thread-based
parallelism
and this is kind of a very very neat
thing to have for a lot of computation
tasks and you do not have to extend the
python interpreter in very bizarre and
weird ways and you do not have to care
about the global interpreter lock
very interesting application i liked it
very much
uh if you are interested in an actual
proof of concept uh demo all the way up
from libsy
from wrapping around numpy like how do
you actually tell an employee to use
shared memory if you want to do it
yourself and how to have something like
p range manually then i compiled it just
for you
otherwise if you're interested in
similar experiments i do quite a bit of
them you can follow me on social media
like on twitter for instance or you can
just have a look at my github profile
so thank you very much
for your attention my apologies for
speaking so fast
it's okay it's so good
thank you so much
thank you thank you so much for being
here with us and for your presentation
sebastian you know it's like sometimes
you have 10 minutes then when i speak so
fast that you want to put everything
that you have there inside yes
we got everything so thank you so much
for being here with us
uh
i would like so we are running a little
bit over on uh
time so what i'm going to do is just
speed up to the next speaker
i would like to introduce now marek
super i'm going to talk about adapters i
need and production enabling trick
for
multitasking multilingual nlp
yeah i don't like the title either thank
you very much for
for using me
so i have about 30 slides and uh
that that means we'll have about 10
seconds for each but i i still i still
think uh we can make it uh rather nicely
so um here's the thing
what do you do if you it's not really a
joke i'm i'm sorry i should have
prepared that way but like we can
probably spin it that way what do you do
if you want to solve in an lp test in
2021 well here's what i would do i'd
basically go to
huggingface.com um check out if there is
a model that could do what what i would
be into um
and if it solves the similar task well i
mean i mean i'm pretty basically golden
i
we i can probably use that if not well
we'll probably take some sort of a large
pre-trained model
that the some large institution has
spent quite a bit of time and resources
on on training and then we'll prob i
will probably fine-tune a couple of uh
well small small parts of it such that
it works nicely on my task
and uh perhaps if i if i felt a little
if i had a bit more time or
or uh if i wasn't really happy with what
i saw i'd probably probably unfreeze a
couple more
of its parts so that it learns at least
a bit better and that's it that i would
i would probably be be
be done with that so well further
forward in six
in six steps you are pretty much done
and you even have a bit of an
optionality here in in three and four
now what do you do if you have a like a
a problem i know a few problems meaning
you do stuff with text with natural
language
but that's not
not really a single task you need but a
multitude multiple tasks
that you need your your model or your um
final deployment to handle well i would
still go to to hugging phase check out
the models there i would still see if
there is a trained model for something
that's very similar to what i would like
to do and if not well again the the
standard stuff or like standard return
models are always well a fairly good
choice at least at least to the first
approximation and now depending on how
many tasks uh we are talking about i'd
probably
go and and uh
and see um see if i could fine-tune at
least the top parts of it for for this
specific test one then i would repeat
two to four meaning these these three
steps for all the tasks i would have
now that's all good because at the end
of the day i would i would probably uh
figure it out this way the problem is
that if you take a something that's a
little bit more complex than just a
single or a or a couple of tasks
something like what do we see on the on
the image towards the bottom which is a
uh basically a a chatbot processing
engine um it starts to become quite a
bit of a hassle mostly because for each
of the tasks that we see in here like
recognizing the intent of a message or
recognizing the entities that are
perhaps being presented in the message
not to mention things like recognizing
um part of speech and and other
interesting things that are normally
standard in in nlp pipelines well each
of these will be its own model and each
of these will be of hundreds of
megabytes in size meaning in in total
will probably have a pretty big pretty
big to massive massive package even if
we go to to models that are distilled or
uh relatively small such as tiny bird
here so the the answer the thing i would
like to show you in here that might be
might be uh
able to to do something with that it was
called adapters and the way adapters
work is a very it is a fairly
straightforward uh kind of a concept um
when you when you normally train the the
whole model the whole transformer as as
you normally would um you basically go
through all the weights that you that
you uh designed to decide to fine-tune
in contrast with adapters
most of the weights stay frozen meaning
they are not changed but a smallish
neural network gets inserted into the
into specific parts of of the
uh of the architecture and it is only
these that are sort of encapsulated as
they call it
that get trained that get updated and
but thanks to this the the existing um
information that's that's basically
being learned by the model can stay the
way it was
what's nice about this is that this way
we still get a scent or a way for the
models for the final model to be to be
sort of focused on our task and our
specific data sets on our specific
problems we have but still
not really
kind of change the whole large model
holage package
now getting back to the multitask
problems there is a couple of a couple
of standard problems that multitask
learning or generally transfer learning
has so first thing is if you
if you throw a bunch of tasks that is
sim and the signal
and the same model there is a very very
strong chance you will
encounter something like catastrophic
influence meaning the fact that there
are um multiple tasks this model needs
to handle means that uh that it will
have a hard time sort of figuring out
what to focus on
not to mention that this can be
massively exacerbated by the fact that
some tasks are more prominent than the
others
you can also perhaps train your model
sequentially meaning you all you train
it on one task on the other task another
third and so on and so forth problem
there is what's called catastrophic
forgetting by the time you show it the
third task is basically forgot what it
was that it was solving in the in the
task it it started with
and so for this the adapters have a
nicely nicely done concept which is
called adapter fusion meaning you
essentially learn a weighting in between
adapters that are trained for specific
tasks and thanks to this again we are
only changing smallish parts of those
models it's easier and faster to train
and but you um as the as the experiments
show you get to a very similar
performance as if you yeah you did it
in in the other
other ways we've been we've been talking
about
so um if you wanted to try something
like this out the the answer is
adapterhap
adapterhub.ml um there is a central
repository of various of these
pre-trained adapter models
and uh
the what adapter transformers the
package they they described there
actually does is that it's a it's a
drop-in replacement for huge increased
transformers so if you use hugging phase
transformers in your in your current
projects there's a very large chance you
could use adapters transformers as well
simply install it and then use it very
similarly to do how you would use uh
tagging phase transformers you only add
a couple more calls in here like load
the specific adapters set it to become
active and then from there on uh then
from there on you use the essentially
the model the way you would use it um if
it if it didn't use adapters at all the
nice thing is that uh although we are
using the bird base and case the
standard model the actual thing that got
downloaded in here or like that would be
a little bit different it's very small
just three megabytes and actually allows
you to the state-of-the-art sentiment uh
sentiment classification this way
provided you already have birds uh
installed somewhere as well and so from
there on it's a very straightforward
it's basically the same thing um the
same thing you would have done you would
have done otherwise and if you want to
train transformers that's a very similar
story as well there are very little very
few changes compared to the from the
standard pipeline that the only thing
that's happening here is that we say yes
please train the adapter that's called
sst
ssd2 here that makes it so that
everything else is frozen in the model
and from there on we basically only set
the
say the adaptive adapters just like
previously add a classification head and
train the model the same way we would um
with other case for hugging phase
transformers
now uh the nice part obviously is that
since we have a since we've added a
small bunch of small bunch of
kind of weights into the large model we
can also save them separately and this
allows us to have these sort of modular
smallish models that we can stack on top
or combine one with another um
within these uh within these normally
massive models uh that would have
otherwise
take quite a bit to learn uh sorry quite
a bit to train and generally to store
and work with so we can nicely say we
can nicely save the adapters that have
been trained to wherever we would want
then you can learn way more on adapter
hub the data ml
they also have quite a few of these
retrained there as well
now i also wanted to point out at least
very quickly that the adapters are being
used in in action despite being an open
area of research one of these uh one of
the examples is called trunkit trunk it
is essentially a spicy alternative it's
a way for you to do standard neural uh
sorry center
yeah natural language processing tasks
um of
for multiple languages they have quite a
few quite a few of them supported uh
roughly over over 50 of those the nice
thing is that every single every single
uh part of or like every module it has
is its own adapters meaning you only
download one model the large uh embed or
something or xml
once and then you only download separate
adapters for each of the languages
meaning the resolving deployment package
if you were to deploy it is much smaller
and much more manageable than if you had
to have large models for every single
language and then using it it's a very
straightforward as you would expect from
something that aims to be a a framework
and so um i guess i guess that's a as a
nice thing to try out if you ever are in
a setup where you need multilingual and
strongest processing supported across
multiple languages
and that's it thank you very much for
having me thank you so much marik for
being with us uh
global 2021
i would like now to hand over to john
mack cambridge and he's going to talk
about lightweight and automated
exploratory data analysis
all right so what i'm going to talk
through here is uh
very bare bones
easily modifiable and very direct uh
lightweight data analysis tool
for very simple exploratory data
analysis
this is probably really helpful to
contrast and compare with what we saw
from diego aida
in that this is designed for a use case
that i constantly found myself in which
is when working with um
older firms uh or data systems uh let's
say in financial services um or when
working with uh smaller
rather non-technical
groups or organizations often charities
or ngos you will necessarily have access
directly to their database um and you
may also
find that they themselves don't really
have any useful ways for you to
work with their data apart from
literally giving you a flat csv
or more likely an excel that you might
turn into a csv so the uh that challenge
is one that i would often deal with when
helping these organizations and i would
find that i would always be doing the
exact same thing much as diego said i
would do the same commands over and over
again trying to explore the data
and this is in the case where you're
given a data file that not only have you
never seen before you have no real
context for it they might not even have
a any kind of metadata available to you
they certainly won't have data types
right because they're just providing you
something out of uh who knows what kind
of system on their side
and so you have no context metadata or
otherwise and it's very likely that the
data itself is pretty messy and nasty
and in ways that they probably don't
even understand or can't tell you about
so what i wanted to do was set up
something that would do what i had
myself did constantly which was poke at
the data one uh column at a time and try
to figure out what was going on in each
one of those as quickly as possible but
without ever letting the machine
guess for me
i think that's one of the big
differences i want to stress here
from some other assistants you might use
which is at no point in time does uh
flenzer try to be smart
uh it will never try to help you by
guessing anything at all it will never
impute anything it will never assume
anything it will only provide you
information that is factually guaranteed
to be true inside of the data and you'll
see that as we as we go forward in here
so the way it executes is incredibly
simple uh you get access to your data
file you run
the python script and it's customizable
in a very simple way which is it allows
you to specify uh um
uh n a values that you know for sure are
n a values that's one of the few things
you might find
you are told or it's something that when
you do your first run with lenser you
immediately find some of these common n
a values that are often non-standard you
can then just integrate those in with
the command line and you'll have a much
cleaner uh experience when you run it
the second time
so
um let me just show you uh what happens
you were given a file let's say these
two files that are scrapped off uh the
internet but more likely you're given
something from some local partner you're
working with uh you execute in your
command line as simple as possible right
you just uh execute the script you can
specify your nas it's a list if you like
um and then it'll just try to open a
simple html file that it will generate
that's itself
and so here is an example one of those
files um there are no visuals in here
the idea is to provide you with raw
information that you can then interpret
yourself
uh so it immediately tells you the
really high level stuff you need to know
about rows and columns it tells you all
the nans it's searched for and it tells
you how many of them it actually found
this is incredibly helpful because often
you'll be told oh yeah we use this nan
value you search for it and actually it
turns out that that doesn't appear
anywhere in the data set and it's
something else it then shows you every
single column and tells you which tests
were triggered inside of the code which
i'll show you shortly you can find all
of these tests and they're incredibly
easy to customize and they do very very
simple things and then provide you with
information again the idea is to try to
just provide you with raw facts about
what's going on in the data it'll also
tell you quickly what anions have found
per column so in some cases there are
none in some cases there are literally
empty cells and in others you see a true
well-formed
n a and then for each of the columns you
literally are just scrolling down this
is a completely flat output you scroll
down you're told the uh column name as
the header which tests triggered and
then based on these tests really simple
diagnostic outputs so for example since
uh it's going to check for unique values
and tell you the count and tell you the
share of non-am nan's right so this will
allow you to know okay how many of my
values are on both non-a and an and
unique this is incredibly useful because
it allows you as was discussed before to
provide find say primary key columns and
so on it will then show you a random
selection of values of that replacement
just to give you some flavor of what
these are
and then it will tell you you know how
many nans did we find how many of the
non-ams are unique all of them can it
therefore function as a unique
identifier and if so what would be the
first value in there you can immediately
start to see oh interesting there this
is only four digits long and yet we're
seeing random samples that are five
digits long and there's no leading zero
so right away you're starting to see
stuff in the data set that you will need
to be keeping in mind about well this is
a unique identifier yet it has no
leading zero so it's non-consistent in
its distribution and then you have since
these are numeric a nice simple quartile
range output showing you mins and counts
and so on
it'll then just move on to the next
column so again you just immediately
start being able to walk through here
and start seeing what are these actually
about we have ident we have type
and you're starting to see information
that will hopefully let your own brain
to make decisions about what any of this
actually is we've right away found that
this is a very simple uh categorical
list which we can then ourselves decide
whether or not we want to declare to be
categorical based on what we're seeing
in the output
and the idea is you simply scroll right
on through you'll come across things
like this this is called latitude deg so
you might imagine it's latitude in
degrees yet let's actually see what are
the outputs and you can actually check
in here that you're seeing interesting
outputs including rather strange ones
like a true minus 90.
uh and you as you scroll through the
data file you'll just get more and more
information some of the columns will
immediately start to reveal themselves
to you like this one in which there are
really just two values a handful of
values and you can just see the examples
here
and you can start making connections
yourself about what any of this
actually means
you'll also see some custom tests in
here for example
trying to detect is these are salesforce
ids it's a very common thing in which
you yourself might be working with the
data set where you know that there's
likely to be salesforce ids possibly
because it literally came out of a
salesforce system but your team that
you're working with the people providing
it to you might not know where the
salesforce ids appear or there might be
random columns that are id columns
they've forgotten about and so this will
do tests to try to find those for you in
this case you can see though it's wrong
these aren't salesforce ids which you
can know yourself
by looking at them so it hasn't presumed
to tell you their sales force ids it
just tells you they might be
and this is a the way that you can use
it you just scroll through and now
having read through it over a couple of
minutes you're able to make your own
decisions about what any of these are
and then you can move forward with much
more complex analyses or work as you see
fit
and you can see that it'll work on file
files that are you know relatively large
in size it's all running locally so
that's part of the design it's not it's
a situation in which all you've been
given is a local file possibly dropped
to a sharepoint or to your
email uh and you're basically told hey
can you help us with this uh and from
there you've got to start doing
something constructive to help them out
you can immediately start seeing things
here for example like how this file
which should be relatively well
formatted nonetheless it's inconsistent
names appearing throughout it that alone
is a big step forward if you're working
with a relatively technically unadvanced
organization where they're just
struggling to understand their basics of
their data set
and then i'll finish here just by
showing you uh some basics in the code
itself it's obviously
kept simply as a single script so it's
incredibly easy to edit
um and one of the simple things that you
can see here is that you can set up more
complex functions to run special tests
for you and then you just populate tests
in here in a data class so if you wanted
to add a new test all you have to do is
just pop it in here into this list of
tests and it will run and execute for
40. these tests can be as complicated or
using functions or as simplistic as you
like in which you know you're just
basically doing what are essentially the
kinds of things you would type by hand
yourself when exploring a data set the
idea though is that every single test
will do a check if the check is true it
will output some kind of output for that
specific column so every single column
gets every single test applied against
it
uh and this is flamster uh it's easy to
use uh and i'd be happy easy to extend
uh and easy to get onto your system all
you need is python uh and the ability to
clone a single git repo
and you're good to go
so be happy to take any questions with
whatever time there is
there are questions
thank you so much john we have 30
seconds left from zazidar is plans there
a python package available at pipey if
not how can i install it
no so right now this is as simple as it
literally exists as a python script that
you can download from git
uh it hasn't even been packaged up you
can see that here the idea was to just
keep this as incredibly simplistic as
possible
um if people find that it's difficult
for them to get access to it in their
particular situation unless it's
elsewhere uh do please let me know in
the chat and we can talk about that it
would be interesting to know if that's a
barrier to people my hope was by keeping
it as simple as literally single script
uxq at the command line um after cloning
the repo that would actually make it as
accessible as possible but i'm really
open to hearing otherwise
thank you so much john for being with us
at pi data global thank you
i would like to hand over now to
christopher uh
that's the last talk for the day
and it's an introduction to the current
information war
hi christopher lozinski here i run
uncensored news.us i put the link in the
chat
um i hope you can see my camera
um
so we're in the middle of uh both
national and international information
wars for our hearts and minds in the u.s
the 2020 election spending
was
14
billion dollars i presume you can see
the shared screen
corporations literally get a great roi
on their lobbying and campaign
contributions
internationally the military
organizations are starting to get
involved here's the french military
strategy in english and in french
here you can hear about nato's policies
and
canada does it they're not the only ones
how do they do it let's examine the
whole information flow chain from the
news source to the journalists through
the network through social media and how
it gets to you the reader once we've
understood the problem it's easy to then
free ourselves at least from the
algorithms and bots
news starts with a source in the u.s
some whistleblowers are not treated well
causing other whistleblowers to
self-censor
next the news gets to the reporters
reporters without borders reports that
50 journalists were killed in 2020.
387 journalists are currently detained
in connection with their work and how
many more are intimidated into
self-censorship or a different career
then the news has to cross the networks
there have been multiple cases of
countries shutting down their entire
network
according to the keep it on coalition in
2020 29 countries around the world
reported to shut downs with 33 in 2019
and 25 and 2018.
then we get to the proprietary
algorithms that determine what we see in
2017 the world socialist website began
documenting that it along with other
less leftist and progressive outlets had
suddenly experienced a dramatic drop in
traffic from google searches this was
later confirmed by the google ceo
[Music]
here we have the youtube ceo saying that
they will actively prioritize corporate
videos over alternative news media
and here's one honest billionaire
stating that he bought politico for
propaganda purposes
you can read more about censorship by
silicon valley
by the mainstream media and by the us
government
you also have to worry about the bots
there are many open source reddit bots
and twitter bots i suspect there are
also some very sophisticated proprietary
bots we did not know about
we also have people being kicked off of
social media while you may not like him
many international leaders including
angela merkel were appalled that
president trump was kicked off of
facebook and twitter without any due
process the 2020 green party candidate
was kicked off temporarily from twitter
how many others have been de-platformed
without or even noticing or worse yet
have their traffic throttled by the
proprietary algorithms what can be done
about this
substack provides a commercial solution
you subscribe to
newsletters either for free or as a
paying subscriber the journalists then
publish both free and paid newsletters
it includes great writers like glenn
greenwald caitlyn johnstone
matt stoller and matt taibi
glenn greenwald knows the substance
staff personally and trusts them they're
of course closed source and practice
surveillance capitalism
ghost.org is another great solution it
is one it is used by my favorite
political commentator bernie sanders
speechwriter david
sirota's daily poster
glenn greenwald has now started his
rumble and my favorite podcast the dark
chord podcast uses odyssey.com having
been demonetized by youtube for
challenging covet orthodoxy
of course there are many websites with
great content but no email newsletter
but you can access both substack and
most website articles using an rss
reader rss is an ancient technology for
accessing the newest articles from your
favorite websites the problem is that
then you get flooded with articles many
of which are junk
i can't do anything about murders
imprisonment or networks going out but
it's quite easy to beat the algorithm's
bots in the platforming uncensored news
not us does this
it pulls in these are the recommended
articles uh so that i've read and
recommend are here you can see the
newest articles uh some of them may not
be so good you can also see the
different categories and click into for
example climate change and see the
articles there you can take a look at
the rss feeds so please visit
uncensorednews.us please follow
uncensored news on
mastodon.social and this is about a
five-minute talk even with a minute
delayed at the front so we should have
time for some questions thank you
thank you so much that's i think a close
for our lightening talks today thank you
everyone for being here uh with us i
thank you so much all the speakers i
hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference thank you so much everyone